let me take my chillin the town of
Prentice essentially essentially of the
white island in the middle of a black
County that's what it amounts to Sheriff
Department and the police department are
viewed separately
mainly because one the Sheriff
Department is predominant black the
police department is predominantly white
we don't try to integrate those
departments and when you have a
community that's divided you have a
community that has predominantly white
police force and with no one to combat
the actions then you get this kind of
thing it's my understanding that when
the police searched Jamie Smith's duplex
that they found a relatively small
amount of marijuana I believe in a bowl
I do know for sure that when they
searched Corey's side of the duplex they
found the remains of a when they found a
roach they found nothing else in his
diplay that was illegal nothing and yet
that was the basis if you believe that
he knew that the police were outside
before he fired that he was going to
kill all the police because he didn't
want to have to pay $100 fine for
possession of a marijuana roach I mean
it does not make sense does not make
sense never asked me never will and it's
curious that Corey's been tried and
convicted and been in Parchman for years
Jamie Smith's never never darkened the
door of the courthouse in Jeff Davis
County even to this day that I know
about and I would have known about it
when a quarry went out to Geo
achieve and they quit coming around as
much because they couldn't stand the
idea coming in he wasn't here self we
just quit having two family dinners and
just pretty much create everything it's
taking a toll on everybody you know and
sometimes it's just hard to get up some
days Cory's family hired defense
attorney Rhonda Cooper to represent him
during the trial during the couple of
years between the time that Cory's trial
lawyer was hired to represent him and
the time he actually went to trial he
actually talked with her a at the most
three times this is a capital murder
charge Stephen Haines who ostensibly is
a forensic pathologist was the state's
expert this is the wlb t6b of reporting
as a medical examiner dr. Stephen Haines
testifies in court on a weekly basis to
his findings from autopsies his business
pathology consultation Incorporated
performs between one and two thousand
autopsies a year but an opinion
editorial in the Wall Street Journal
over the weekend accuses dr. Haines of
making mistakes in those autopsies
because he performs too many senior
editor of Reason magazine Radley Balko
also claims Haines testimony about his
findings often falls in line with what
the prosecution is trying to prove dr.
Haines says he is certified but could
not remember the name of the
organization when we spoke with him he
testified it was impossible for court
have been lying sitting or lying on the
floor into a fire an upward angle at Ron
Jones and that bullet to have come down
at an angle like it was in Ron's body
well that was later proved to be not
scientific not correct actually Corey
had no expert to come in and testify on
his behalf
that hey that's bogus science it could
that trajector that bullet could easily
being explained where it would match the
trajectory of the bullet in the
doorframe that's on an upward angle I
think from the get-go from the
preliminary hearing on up I don't think
that I know that there were things done
that I would have done very differently
that I think any most any other defense
lawyer you would have done very
differently blue panes that allow you
should know how to do she didn't know
how to do it on January 24th 2004 after
a little more than an hour of
deliberation a jury of 10 white men and
two black women found Corey May guilty
of murder in the first degree
later that afternoon the same jury
sentenced Corey May to death that was
the hardest day of all when they say
yeah that very day when they read their
verdict their lawyer looked at me and I
knew she was she looked at me and died
and she had tears in the eyes and I said
well I'm not going to crack her I'm you
know I'm sure damn you know I'm not
going to cry but when he looked at me
and he threw his Fang up and kids you
know kiss me when desired that's what
made me start crying he just kept saying
mom I love you please take care much
and I still have a hard time with that
because I know I know ain't no way he
would I did anything to jeopardize him
being home with his family and
especially his kids you know it all
depends on who you're asking whether the
shooting was justified or not if you ask
the black people they feel strong like I
do yeah I think that most of the
community think that because the officer
died is very tragic because we know both
families but being that the situation
was like it was I think it was justified
I think most of the community agree that
it was a justified act the reaction of
the population of the town of Prentiss
in general was certainly and they were
they were glad the court was convicted
and sentenced to death in fact some of
the people that I personally know of
were joyful I'd say that but they were
back home